[Applause]
it is clearly so exciting for people to
see the two of us together I have a
confession to make which is we didn't
really meet but we met in a way a couple
of years ago but you probably won't
remember no and I'll excuse you okay
most people think I'm Ralph Malph from
Happy Days Ritchie yes I went I was in
Washington DC about two and a half years
ago doing an event I got back from the
event late at night they put me up with
this nice hotel I walked through the
lobby I'm really tired I get on the
elevator the elevator door starts to
close you know you're really tired the
elevator was closing and someone shouted
out hold the door
hold the elevator and I went to hit the
button and then thought it's it was like
too much to lean over to hit the button
I was like and I just lean back and I
don't hit the button and as the doors
closing I see your face in the closing
door looking angrily at me and did and
the door shut and I was like tonight no
no please please please stay I didn't
realize I was tired let me I was tired
too
No maybe you had a big day I had a big
date I'm sorry I big of me to relive
this moment I think I could have just
forgotten it but I felt I should bring
it up and in fact I went up the stairs
floors are somewhat defined you
I heard someone banging on my door about
half an hour later you recognized you
but I was looking for the big mean guy
sorry I'm glad I found you yeah no let's
straighten this out first of all I want
people to relive the horror of what that
was like for me and we can recreate this
right now if you'd be so good Harrison
to look into that camera right now
you're tired you're angry you're you're
tired and angry and then you make Ike
now it's only fair to recreate what it
must have been like for you to see this
[Applause]
I mean you're the kind of you have so
much clout you could easily have me
killed no no it's all in the works right
now no well we're very happy that you're
here congratulations the the number one
movie cool thing for the moment Wow you
know something I don't know I'm very
pleased that the response has been great
yeah it's interesting because free I
mean you you you are famous for being
very cool headed you don't you you are I
think you're very you're a very cool guy
you don't get excited if I was in the
number one movie I'd be stirring the pot
dancing wearing a thong I'd be jumping
around I'd be very excited to say the
least what excites you I mean if not
being in the number one movie doesn't do
it what really makes Harrison Ford wig
out I I guess I don't wig out you know
even if the following things happened
what if you were to we have a few
demonstrations here what would you get
excited if you got to play bass with
limp Biskit with this excite here
did that get you gone what if you got to
go streaking would that really get you
going what if we gave you a chance to
actually be reborn what if you could be
reborn wouldn't that get you excited
right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
come on I didn't need to know that
that's why I didn't let you on the
elevator all right now let's stop at the
film what lies beneath scary movie uh
yeah very I think it's it's a thriller
it's a psychological scary rather than
slasher scary right is that which can
actually be scarier a lot of times I
think so yeah this is what's I mean do
you like scary movies in general is that
something you enjoy god no you don't
really like them no I I I'm glad there
are people that like him but I don't
think yeah I don't really go to scary
movies what was the scariest movie you
ever saw be vampy dude really
yes I did I saw Bambi a long time ago
maybe you saw a different version that's
really scary virgin real I saw the
French version this really it was and it
was very scary
no it's scary I mean the loss of a
mother that sort of thing is scary right
psychologically scary yeah do you get
scared a lot and you scare easily
what do you think No see what I mean I
so committed to this yeah that's my
charm that's a can we say that's my
charm it's a comedy rule commit I heard
that you're thinking of doing another
Indiana Jones movie is that true or not
nice good
yeah I'm gonna do it alone in my
backyard
[Laughter]
you know on video I'm gonna do it yeah
it'll be great
no I would love to do one we're waiting
to have a script find a time for
Spielberg and Lucas and I to get
together yeah people will never get
tired of that genre you could do it for
I mean you could when you're 80 you
could do ones where they just bring the
treasures to you and you're good job
just something to think about Indiana
Jones and the comfortable bed put that
with the rest of them over there
now before you go I have to ask you
you're of course probably one of the
biggest stars we ever had on this show
although mr. T's coming up tomorrow so
don't get a swelled head what now a lot
of times big stars they have to leave
right away and I'm wondering is there
any way we could get you to stay until
the very end of the show at 1:30 for the
credits cuz that would look so cool 1:30
you don't think so huh you're a busy guy
you can't do it I would love to stay I
really would yeah but I have some
cookies in the oven lamest thing
anyone's ever said to me what if we did
this what if we shot the ending of the
show now and we throw it in there and
then that way you can we can throw it at
the end of the show and then people
watching the show will think that you
stayed till the end of the show how's
that sad no folks thanks for sticking
all the way to the end of the show I
can't believe Caroline Ray had to run
and you stayed I hit max good night
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]